[موسيقى] [
موسيقى] أجنبية [
موسيقى]
يتمتع جو بطاقة أكبر من 40 عامًا كما
تعلم ، وانظر إلى كل ما فعله في
السنوات الثلاث الماضية ، أعني أنه في
إدارتنا جمعه معًا ،
تعرف كلا جانبي الممر
الجمهوريين  والديمقراطيين وكان
لديه العديد من
البرامج التي تعرف أنها
أفادت الناس في الولايات المتحدة ،
أعني أنه يمكنني إدراجها ولكنك تعلم مثل
برنامج البنية التحتية أو
خطة الإنقاذ الأمريكية للمساعدة في
مكافحة الوباء ، فقط أشياء كثيرة لتخفيف الديون
مؤخرًا و  أنت تعلم أنني لا أعتقد أنك
بحاجة إلى النظر إلى عمره ، فأنت بحاجة إلى إلقاء نظرة
على ما أنجزه وما
يفعله الآن وما الذي
سيستمر في القيام به لشعب
الولايات المتحدة
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك أعني أنني
أستمع  له أنت تعلم أنه
يستمع إلي ، أعيد القصص
عندما أسافر ، أخبرهم عن جميع
الأطفال الذين أقابلهم وأم تعرف
القصص اللطيفة المضحكة تتذكر الأطفال الذين
كانوا يتعلمون اللغة الإنجليزية من خلال غناء
الأغنية الأمريكية ولذا أحاول إحضار  له
الجانب الإنساني القصص الإنسانية
وهكذا لأنه في كثير من الأحيان يسافر إلى
البلدان وقد لا يرى ذلك
لأنه أه لأنه في لقاءات معكم
تعرف قادة البلد لذلك
أحاول جلب العنصر البشري
[موسيقى]
شكرا لك
أجنبية